اذا الاطاحه بشرطه الاخلاق واعاده النظر
بمواد الدستور الايراني لم يطح بعزيمه
المحتاجين على استكمال انتفاضاتهم لاسقاط
النظام المحتجون دعوا الى اضراب عام في
كافه انحاء البلاد بدءا من اليوم وستستمر
الى بعد غد الاضرابات شملت معظم المدن
الايرانيه كما نشاهد على هذه الخريطه
وابرزها طهران اصفهان كارمن شاه قزوين
وكردستان وغيرها طبعا من المدن الايرانيه
فالمحلات التجاريه في سوق نقش جهان
التاريخي الذي تاسس قبل 500 عام في اصفهان
تم اغلاقها بالكامل كما سنشاهد بهذه الصور
[موسيقى]
اريد اريد
كامل
سببها سلار وهو اكبر اسواق العاصمه في
مشاهدت مدينه كرمان جنوب شرق البلاد
اضرابا عاما فلنتابع ايضا المشاهد منه
هناك
[موسيقى]
ساريه السريه